what do you want this week trying to get
all the dick you wanna hold what do you
want oh oh
backwash oh [ __ ] I haven't been this
hungover since last weekend oh it
doesn't feel good in here we have to
make some changes yeah maybe we just
stick to cider for a while
Parrish it were just as like a week
seven days is nothing dude it's got to
be like 30 oh my god could you not do 30
days [ __ ] you I can okay I just I don't
want to I don't want to go three days
without eating junk but I'm gonna do it
I could do it
we can do it no drinking no junk food we
can do it you know what fine
so let's [ __ ] do it yeah let's do it
30 days okay
starting today what in three Oh bah -
lets go
we forgot it was Game of Thrones tonight
it's my mom's birthday happy birthday
mom coming back it's raining what is the
copy without a biscotti biscotti palace
good point
it's bomb it's okay
it's our first day it's free what am I
not gonna get free Italia dies idiots
beer out but they were out of salads - I
swear
he bought it for me hey I'm Marvin talk
to me Gabby Douglas eats pizza all the
time so I'm her today okay it looks like
I have 30 days free coming up in June
2028 that's great
that is fantastic just send me a cal
invite why did you make us do this well
we didn't do it right if anything we
just proved that we couldn't really
don't like mice I don't know like who
I've become
thank you I hate it I like you too I
like you know I let's go to big Wang's